l'équilibre des relations commerciales
au sein de la chaîne agroalimentaire et
à travers lui la juste rémunération de
chacun des maillons de la chaîne au
premier rang desquels nos agriculteurs
c'est le débat au fond auquel nous
invite collectivement cette proposition
de loi c'est là le débat que vous avez
souhaité avoir aujourd'hui en vous en
saisissant pleinement ce sujet est une
actualité forte pour plusieurs filières
et plusieurs maillons de notre chaîne
alimentaire notre défi commun celui du
gouvernement de l'Assemblée nationale
comme du Sénat j'en suis persuadé et
d'assurer notre souveraineté alimentaire
avec nos agriculteurs et au service de
notre pays et de nos concitoyens il est
aussi de notre devoir collectif
gouvernement parlementaire agriculteurs
industriels distributeurs citoyens de
trouver et proposer des solutions pour
nous assurer collectivement que nous
conserverons une capacité à produire
dans tous les territoires dans tous vos
territoires pour nous alimenter en
qualité et en quantité suffisante dans
les décennies à venir
c'est un objectif fondamental et qui
doit être très largement partagé car
comme j'ai l'habitude de le rappeler
chacun de ces maillons s'inscrits dans
une relation d'interdépendance forte qui
les oblige ou devraient les obliger à
une récip responsabilité réciproque de
la capacité de nos agriculteurs à
dégager des revenus ce qui est en soit
un enjeu primeurdial dépend aussi la
résilience de l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire en définitive on peut dire
que c'est de cette capacité à dégager de
la valeur que dépend la résidence et la
souveraineté alimentaire agricole de
notre pays soyons lucides ces défis se
posent à l'ensemble de la chaîne les
agriculteurs bien sûr aux industriels et
au distributeurs dans des modalités
différentes certes mais de façon tout
aussi prégnante j'aimerais revenir sur
ce sujet parce que trop de propos vers
ce trop facilement sur ces sujets dans
la caricature souvent dans des enceintes
extérieures au Parlement ce texte vise à
un meilleur équilibre des relations
commerciales
mais il ne s'agit pas de monter les
distributeurs contre les industriels ou
l'inverse notre souveraineté alimentaire
et la sécurité de nos approvisionnements
sont des préoccupations partagées par
tous
par tous les Français également il faut
le dire par l'ensemble des maillons de
notre chaîne alimentaire
en particulier dans le contexte que nous
connaissons qui rappelle à chaque un
silenté était besoin le caractère
objectif stratégique pardon de ces
objectifs notre sécurité notre
souveraineté alimentaire dépend de
chacun des trois maillons de la chaîne
prix individuellement et collectivement
cette délicate recherche de l'équilibre
dans quelque part nous inviter à la
mesure et à la tempérance avant de venir
au texte soumis à votre champ je veux
rapidement rappeler le chemin qui a été
parcouru lors du précédent quinquennat
pour améliorer le revenu de nos
agriculteurs réécrit livrés les
relations commerciales et mieux encadrer
des pratiques afin de sécuriser l'avenir
de nos filières agricoles et
agroalimentaire c'est le fruit de deux
lois égaline 1 et Gallim 2 la seconde
étant d'ailleurs le produit d'une
évaluation à l'Assemblée nationale comme
au Sénat qui ont déjà donné des
résultats concrets la loi également est
venue renforcer le formalisme juridique
du contrat à Lamon à Laval le relèvement
du seuil de revente à perte et
l'encadrement des promotions en valeur
et en volume
aux promotions agressives destructrice
de valeur et déroutante tant pour les
consommateurs que pour les agriculteurs
la loi egalim 2 est venue renforcer la
construction en marche avant si vous me
permettez de cette expression du prix
depuis le producteur vers le
distributeur à la mode agricole le
principe est désormais celui d'une
contractualisation écrite plus réelle et
obligatoire concrètement les contrats
doivent comprendre un certain nombre de
clauses qui sécurisent les agriculteurs
et leur donne de la visibilité sur leur
rémunération je pense notamment aux
clauses de révision automatique des prix
à la valve de nombreuses mesures ont été
introduites comme la transparente et la
non négociabilité de la matière première
agricole le rééquilibrage des relations
a été constaté dès la fin du cycle des
négociations commerciales annuelles qui
s'est achevé le 1er mars 2022 il a
bénéficié à nos agriculteurs et à nos
transformateurs en permettant pour la
première fois
de mettre fin à ce qui avait été
constaté par tous depuis 10 ans la
spirale destructrice de la guerre des
prix sur les produits agricoles en
particulier la transparence et la
non-négociabilité de la matière première
ont donné des résultats très
encourageants naturellement parce qu'il
faut être modeste du chemin reste à
parcourir et je sais les difficultés qui
subsistent mais les lois égalées m'ont
contribué à permettre le maintien dans
nos territoires de nombreuses
exploitations agricoles et apposées
clairement la question de la
rémunération les décrets d'application
opportant sur nos relations commerciales
sont pour la quasi-totalité adoptée tous
ceux qui étaient indispensables au bon
fonctionnement de la loi l'ont été des
fins 2021 il revient évidemment aux
acteurs de s'en saisir dans un contexte
qui est particulier celui de la guerre
en Ukraine qui est venu perturber le
cycle comme vous le savez de négociation
nous devons donc absolument éviter de
fragiliser cet édifice dont la mise en
oeuvre pleine et entière ne débute que
cette année c'est notamment le cas pour
de nombreuses PME qui avait conclu leur
négociation en 2021 avant l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi egalim 2 à cet égard
une des propositions de la commission
des affaires économiques avec la
commission des affaires économiques à
est adopté me semblait aller sans doute
un rebours des efforts collectifs que
nous avions réalisés et par un chevet
avec la loi egalim je pense aux articles
2 et 2 ter B qui prévoyaient de mettre
un coup d'arrêt à expérimentation des
dispositifs et CRP + 10
cette proposition pouvait porter me
semble-t-il atteinte à l'équilibre
financier de nombreuses entreprises et
risquaient de mettre à mal tous les
efforts que nous avons collectivement
ici avec le Sénat également engagé pour
changer de paradigme au sein des
relations commerciales depuis les lois
égalimes 1 et 2 ce cycle a été
interrompu désormais les anciennes
concepts plus facilement les demandes
des hausses de tarifs si celles-ci sont
convenablement documentées et objectifs
certains diront que ce n'est pas assez
ils ont sans doute raison ou peut-être
raison de diront que l'épreuve de
l'efficacité du système reste à prouver
en oubliant de dire à l'inverse qui
n'existe aucune preuve c'est d'ailleurs
ce que disent un certain nombre de
rapports que cette suspension ne prouve
que pas elle-même des effets néfastes
quoi qu'il en soit nous devons
reconnaître qu'un contexte nouveau c'est
instauré depuis plusieurs années et que
ce dispositif expérimental il y a de
toute évidence l'argument contribué
suspendre pendant deux ans cette
expérimentation serait revenue si disons
le clairement à l'enterrer cette
proposition portait donc en elle pour
nous un risque de relancer la guerre des
prix la destruction de valeur
j'ajoute que c'est une conviction que je
voulais vous partager j'aimerais vous
dire que ce serait sans doute mortifère
de glisser doucement vers un débat qui
opposerait revenu des agriculteurs et
protections du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages en particulier les plus modestes
comme si l'un ne pouvait se faire qu'au
détriment de l'autre car ce sont ces
deux combats que nous devons mener de
front et c'est ce à quoi s'emploie ce
gouvernement avec égaline d'une part et
avec toutes les mesures que nous mettons
dans l'oeuvre pour protéger les Français
de l'inflation notamment alimentaire
d'autre part ne tombons pas dans le
piège qui consisterait opposé ce que
certains essayent de faire d'ailleurs
les difficultés des uns à celles des
autres et à ce moment ensemble un
discours public clair sur le prix du
travail des agriculteurs qui n'est pas
le prix le plus bas mais le juste prix
celui qui les rémunère enfin j'ajoute un
dernier élément l'évaluation de cette
expérimentation a déjà été rendue
difficile par la succession de crise
sanitaires et de choc inflationniste
ce qui permet au passage de relativiser
les critiques qui ont pu entendre ici ou
là l'évaluation économique d'une telle
expérimentation est complexe et en
modifier les paramètres vient à en
sacrifier pour moi toute l'ambition
d'avoir à terme une évaluation fiable et
nous avons besoin d'être violation sur
ce dispositif on demande et m'agresse
certaines critiques des enseignements
sont quand même attirés de deux rapports
d'évaluation remis au Parlement qui
démontent que l'effet inflationniste
attribuable à sa mesure a été plus que
marginal et je suis persuadé que les
dispositifs de contrôle et d'évaluation
seront de nature à nos éclairer encore
sur ce dispositif du SRP + 10 c'est sans
doute cela la logique que nous devons
privilégier mieux évaluer avec le
Parlement plutôt que suspense dispositif
et prend le risque d'affaiblir la portée
des lois et galimes je crois madame la
rapporteur madame la Présidente que vous
avez su être à l'écoute de ces
inquiétudes qui ont pu être exprimées je
salue les premières évolutions que vous
avez proposées la maman que vous
défendrez en séance publique visée
finalement à maintenir l'expérimentation
nous en reparlerons tout à l'heure et
c'est un objectif que nous partageons je
reste réservé mais nous en parlerons
tout sur plusieurs points de la
rédaction sur le fait de déconnecter les
dates pour le SRP et celle de
l'encadrement des promotions d'une part
et sur l'exclusion des fruits et légumes
mais je le répète nous en parlerons tout
à l'heure concernant le relèvement du
seuil de revente à perte et
l'encadrement des promotions il y a une
autre proposition à l'article de terre B
que je dois l'avouer m'interroge et
interroge le gouvernement il s'agit de
l'élargissement de l'encadrement des
promotions on produit de la droguerie
parfumerie et hygiène vous les
élargissez ce dispositif pourtant conçu
pour répondre d'abord il nous
semble-t-il aux spécificités de la
chaîne agroalimentaire à des produits de
consommation et à des acteurs
économiques en tout points différents et
c'est aussi l'occasion pour moi de
rappeler avec force que produire pour
nourrir n'est pas une activité comme les
autres et cette singularité c'est un
élément pour moi de fierté pour nos
agriculteurs aussi pour nous qui avons
conscience ici au Sénat comme ailleurs
que l'agriculture est une part de notre
histoire et qu'elle participe à la place
de la France dans le monde à la vitalité
au dynamisme économique des territoires
et pour toutes ces raisons il me semble
que le fruit du travail agricole doit
être mis un peu à façon j'oublierai ce
que vous dites par ailleurs sur les
autres entreprises concernées et qui
peuvent avoir leur propre spécificité il
est donc important pour moi de revenir à
l'essentiel et pour en conclure Madame
la Présidente donnons-nous trois années
supplémentaires pour évaluer
correctement l'expérimentation prolongée
à périmètre constant en lien étroit avec
le Parlement et ce sera d'ailleurs
l'esprit des évolutions que le
gouvernement proposera et qui font les
causes amendements d'un certain nombre
de groupes j'en terminerai en soulignant
de nombreuses avancées permissent par ce
texte que le Sénat a contribué très
largement à améliorer après l'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale il me semble que
le reste du texte poursuit sa volonté la
volonté initiée par leur éditeur initial
de la proposition loi Frédéric
desrosailles les pénalités logistiques
sont mieux encadrées avec des
obligations plus précises et des
sanctions alourdies nous nous approchons
par ailleurs du bien plus juste
équilibre chers
ministre de l'économie et la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
sur l'article 3 visant à mieux encadrer
les cas ou un accord n'a pu être conclu
entre distributeurs et fournisseurs au
1er mars je tiens à saluer le travail
extrêmement précis et pointu par la
rapporteur et votre commission sur ce
sujet plus globalement je voudrais
saluer la qualité des travaux menés par
Madame la rapporteur et madame la
Présidente de la Commission je souhaite
les remercier pour les améliorations
qu'elles ont contribué à apporter au
texte et le témoigne de l'engagement que
vous portez depuis longtemps sur ces
sujets et de la vigilance également que
vous portez sur ce sujet ces engagements
nous les avons en commun ce texte dans
sa version issue des travaux de
l'Assemblée nationale a été adopté à
l'unanimité je sais pouvoir aussi
compter sur le Sénat pour que nous
puissions avoir des débats approfondis
et que la sagesse connue des sénateurs
permettent en définitive que nous
aimerions ensemble au service de ce
sujet d'intérêt national qui est notre
agriculture et notre souveraineté
alimentaire